- [Voiceover] In this video,
we're going to be talking about
how you can find the units
for your rate constant k.
So the two things you should
know before we get started
are that, one, rate constant k has units.
So this isn't always true
of constants in chemistry,
but it is true of k.
The second thing to remember is that
your rate constant, the units of k depend
on your rate law.
And so we're going to
use this second point
to use the rate law to
derive the units of k.
And this is really
handy because that means
you don't have to memorize
what the units of k are
for different orders of reactions.
So we're going to focus on the
three most common rate laws
that you see in chemistry class.
So we're going to talk about
zeroth, first, and second
order reactions.
And we will derive their units.
So first, let's look at zeroth order.
So zeroth order reactions
have a rate law that look like this.
So the rate is equal to k times
the concentration of your reactant A
to the zeroth power.
And anything to the
zeroth power is just one.
So our rate is equal
to the rate constant k.
The units of rate are
always going to be the same.
So the units of rate are
always molar per second
and you can also just think
of units almost like numbers.
If you have an equal sign,
the units on both sides
of your equal sign have to be the same
and they have to match.
So here, since we have rate equal to k,
that means k must also have
units of molars per second.
So this tell us that the units
for a zeroth order reaction
are molar per second.
We can use that same idea
to figure out the units of k
for first and second order reactions, too.
So for a first order reaction,
so for first order,
a first order reaction rate law is
rate is equal to our rate constant k
times the concentration of our reactant
raised to the first power.
Units of rate are molar per second,
and the units of concentration are always
going to be molar.
So now we know that the
units of k times molar
equals molar per second.
So we have molar on both sides,
so we don't have to worry about that,
but we're missing a
one over a second term.
So that tells us that the units
of k are one over seconds.
The other way that we can try
to figure out the units here,
if you're not comfortable
with back-calculating
what the units are, is we can actually
rearrange this rate law,
So if we just put k on one side
and everything else on the other side,
we get that k is equal to rate
divided by the concentration of A.
So all I did was divide both sides here
by the concentration of A.
And since we know that the units
on both sides of the equal
sign have to be the same,
then we can figure out the units of k
by dividing the units of rate
by the units of our concentration.
So that's just molar per
second, for the rate,
divided by molar,
for the concentration.
And then the molar cancels out,
and we're left with one over seconds.
So that's an even more
straight-forward way
to find the units of k.
But the idea is the same.
You can treat units the
same way you treat numbers,
and you just have to make sure they match
on both sides of your equal sign.
The last example we're going to go through
is going to be for second order reactions.
So second order reactions,
or second order rate laws
have the form
rate is equal to our rate constant k
times the concentration of our reactant
to the second power.
So on one side, we have
molar per second for the rate
and on the other side, now,
since our concentration is squared,
we have molar squared.
So molar squared times something
is equal to molar per second.
We need to add a one over seconds
in our units for k because
we need to make sure
when we multiple these, we
get the seconds on the bottom,
and we need to cancel out one
of these concentration terms,
so we need to put molar in
the denominator as well.
So the units of k for
a second order reaction
are one over molar,
molar-seconds.
so these are the three
most common molecularities
that you might see in a chemistry class.
And sometimes, you have reactions
that aren't zeroth,
first, or second order,
and whenever that happens,
you can always use the rate law
to find the units of the rate constant k.